it's just passed 15 GMT that's 6 p.m in
the Ukrainian Capital Kiev where
President Vladimir zielinski has
confirmed a counter-offensive is now
underway however he didn't provide
further details the operation had been
expected to start soon Ukrainian forces
have made gains in the East near the
devastated city of bahmut they are
aiming to encircle that city which
Russian forces seized back in May on
Friday Russian President Vladimir Putin
said that Ukraine's counter-offensive
had begun and was already failing this
was zelinski's response to that
it's interesting that Putin should be
talking about our counter-offensives
it's important that Russia should feel
always that it's not a long way ahead of
us the counter-offensive and defensive
actions are taking place in Ukraine I
will not speak about which phase they're
in but I would not trust various
telegram channels about it or in
particular Putin
so we're following this story from both
sides of the conflict Daniel Hawkins is
in the Russian Capital Moscow first
though we're going to start with Charles
Stratford from the front lines in
kramatorsk in eastern Ukraine Charles
you spent time with the Ukrainian
military today what can you share with
us
yes that's right we went to the town or
the large Village of chasive Yar with a
Ukrainian unit
um an artillery unit now Chas if you are
is important because it is basically
it's the first large settlement that you
come to before bahmoud it's about 10 to
15 kilometers a bit further maybe to
Bahamut from there but it is key because
it is one of the big lines of both
defense and now according to president
zielinski offense as part of this
counter offensive
um what we were shown were as I say
artillery positions that were firing on
Russian positions to the south of
bahmoud in what military analysts call
softening operations basically probing
areas for weaknesses in Russian defense
before pushing forward they were telling
us the ukrainians that they were making
gradual gains both to the south of
bakmut and to the north of Bahamut as
well coming coming in from the North in
an area we believe to be around the town
of solidar and of course Mahmoud is
completely controlled
according to the Russians by Russian
forces the ukrainians dispute this and
they are now saying that they are
pushing from the south to around a one
kilometer a day into those Russian
positions and they told us that that
could be anything from five meters one
day to you know 500 meters another day
they're finding it very difficult indeed
to do that we heard certainly from the
positions that we were at we heard
virtually no incoming nothing that was
clearly discernible as incoming from the
Russian side but a lot of outgoing
shelling by the ukrainians as I say in
these softening operation looking for
weak spots in Russia's defenses there
now whether this represents a
large-scale push if you like in this
counter-offensive that is highly
unlikely I think a lot of eyes are on
that area south of the town the city of
zaprasia that front line there around
the town of um
where we saw this incident yesterday
which now increasingly the ukrainians
seem to be acknowledging certainly the
Russians saying that they took a number
of leopard two tanks and these modern
tanks that have been given by Ukraine's
allies as well as a lot of infantry
fighting vehicles too that's seemingly
where there is a bigger push happening
but it is still too early to say whether
either of these fronts represent
something large scale I think it's more
likely that what we're seeing at the
moment are the beginnings of these
pushes testing those defensive lines
before something more large scale begins
Charles let's try and talk a little bit
bigger picture and I know the ukrainians
have been very tight-lipped about this
counter-offensive but are you able to
discern what their military objectives
are
it's very difficult to say of course
according the official line from
president zielinski is that they will
not stop until they have reclaimed in
their words liberated all the territory
that Russia has occupied since 2014. now
that is a vast area and of course it
would include the Crimean Peninsula I
think it's more likely that's according
certainly to military analysts and and
Western intelligence agencies for
example that share information they say
that it's more likely that what the
ukrainians are aiming to do is cause as
much of a in their words catastrophic
failure amongst Russian forces in order
to push President Putin the Russian
leader into some sort of negotiated
settlement or a situation where he is
forced to negotiate that is not a
zero-sum game by any stretch according
to to analysts they're saying that look
if the ukrainians can win enough on the
battlefield then that may eventually
involve President Putin having to
basically push back another
counter-offensive by the Russians if
that involved a large-scale conscription
effort trying to get more Russian men on
the battlefield many analysts would say
that that could potentially cause big
instability and problems for Putin
politically inside Russia but of course
we are a long long way for anything from
anything like that happening at the
moment I think most analysts will say
the concentration of this
counter-offensive as I say seems to be
potentially south of zaparisia and the
reason is is because they're trying to
that land bridge that we so often talk
about that land bridge from the areas
that are Russian occupied in Donetsk and
lugansk down to the Crimean Peninsula if
they can cut that land bridge then that
isolates Crimea everything apart from
that Kirch bridge and it would not be
inconceivable According to some analysts
as if if eventually the ukrainians start
when they're in range trying to smash
that bridge as well it's that kind of
pressure that according to analysts the
ukrainians are trying to put on Russia
it's not going to involve according to
most Ukraine taking back all the
territory that it's lost to Russia since
2014. and Charles thank you very much
that's all very helpful I know you and
your team are going to go and put
together a report with what you filmed
today we look forward to watching that
let me bring in now uh journalist Daniel
Hawkins in Moscow what Daniel what's
Russia saying about this
counter-offensive so far
well it's clear from the Russian Mod's
Daily Briefing released just hours ago
there is a major intensification in
fighting not only on the southern so
what is your front but also on the
Donetsk front Russian officials are
claiming major losses for the Ukrainian
military around 300 military personnel
as well as close to a dozen tanks close
to two dozen other uh infantry fighting
and armored vehicles many of those have
been alleged to be leopard tanks and
Bradley Fighting vehicles and those
claims appear to be confirmed by Drone
footage released both by the Russian mod
and wall bloggers which certainly appear
to show Columns of this Western supplied
Weaponry are burning on the battlefield
now there have been contradictory claims
about what's going on in Bahamut the
Ukrainian side saying they've succeeded
in pushed and Russian forces away from
the flanks of that in battle City the
Russian side saying those offensives
have failed and the attacks have been
repelled interestingly War
correspondence here in Russia also
commenting on the fact Ukrainian forces
are using their more Advanced Equipment
to their advantage that includes stuff
like night Optics thermal imaging
goggles which enable them to fight these
battles and launch these attacks pretty
much 24 7. and that's something
apparently which the Russian army lacks
something Vladimir Putin Vladimir Putin
commented on yesterday saying these
issues do exist but they're being
rectified those issues are being
addressed the Russians do have an aerial
Advantage they're using their dominance
in the skies to launch strikes they say
on command centers on ammunition supply
lines Logistics lines way behind the
front lines targeting these Ukrainian
Depots in the kharkiv curacon and the
porosia trying to disrupt this offensive
before it's really taken forth and taken
hold fully I think it's clear in the
coming hours and days there's going to
be an intensification in these battles
especially on the southern front as
Ukrainian forces look to probe the
Russian defenses and find weak spots and
the Russian army looks to dig in and
keep those positions they've been
entrenched in over the past weeks and
months before potentially launching a
counter-offensive of the I think we'll
get more information on that as it comes
in over the coming hours and days Daniel
Hawkins reporting from Moscow thank you
very much